Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Buongiorno!
La matematica nel cuore perché...
è la passione che
ci guida come matematici.
La matematica per il cuore
perché voglio convincervi
che la matematica è anche utile
per noi, per la nostra salute.
Perché?
Perché le malattie del nostro sistema
cardiocircolatorio sono molto importanti.
Riescono a impattare in termini mortali
il 45% della popolazione
nei paesi ricchi, nei paesi occidentali,
con un costo economico, un costo sociale
straordinariamente grande.
Si stima che siano circa
200 miliardi di euro per anno,
si stima che sia questo l'impatto
sull'economia di un continente
come l'Europa.
Eppure l'80% circa delle malattie
delle nostre sistema cardiovascolare
sono in qualche modo preventivabili.
Questo è il ruolo, il punto
in cui la matematica può inserirsi,
questa è la nicchia di intervento
della matematica.
Vogliamo utilizzare la matematica
per cercare di aiutare i medici, i clinici
a meglio comprendere
il nostro sistema cardiocircolatorio
e, se è possibile, a meglio curare
persone che sono affette da patologie
e anche, eventualmente,
meglio progettare interventi chirurgici
che siano più efficaci
per persone che ne abbiano bisogno.
Il cuore ha sostanzialmente
quattro camere: due atri e due ventricoli.
Il sangue venoso entra dalla vena cava,
viene poi spedito ai polmoni,
dove viene ossigenato,
ritorna attraverso le vene
polmonari nell'atrio sinistro
e poi, attraverso la valvola mitrale,
entra nel ventricolo sinistro
e da qui, attraverso la valvola aortica,
entra nel sistema circolatorio globale
attraverso l'arteria aorta.
Un sistema estremamente complesso,
richiede un sincronismo perfetto.
Ci sono grandi deformazioni,
grandi spostamenti,
una grande torsione, e una contrazione
e dilatazione del nostro cuore,
ci sono le valvole che si aprono
e si chiudono in maniera molto rapida
ed è esattamente
grazie a questo sincronismo
che il cuore può funzionare
così come funziona.
Quello che vedete è un cuore vero,
questa è una pulsazione vera,
è un'immagine presa
ovviamente in tempo reale.
Vi rendete conto di quanto complesso
sia il meccanismo di funzionamento.
La potenza che esprime il cuore
è straordinaria
potete farvi un'idea, pensando,
se avete mai fatto
un esperimento di questo tipo,
alla compressione di un pallina da tennis
e alla forza che ci vuole,
il lavoro che dovete produrre
per schiacciare una pallina da tennis.
Questo è confrontabile
in termini dimensionali
al lavoro che il cuore fa in ogni secondo
per permettere a questa cavità, struttura,
che è quasi completamente cava,
di spedire il sangue
al nostro sistema circolatorio.
Si stima che nell'arco di un ciclo di vita
il cuore riesca a mandare
nel nostro sistema circolatorio
l'equivalente di un milione e mezzo
di barili di sangue,
quindi uno sforzo veramente titanico.
Ed è una scintilla che
ci dà la vita in ogni secondo.
È una scintilla, è un pacemaker naturale,
che parte dal nodo seno atriale
e si diffonde poi attraverso un sistema
complesso di fibre, le fibre del Purkinje,
nell'intero miocardio.
Ogni cellula del nostro miocardio
viene coinvolta, viene attivata,
questo dà luogo per un complesso
meccanismo biochimico,
ad una contrazione, oppure
ad una dilatazione di queste cellule
e l'effetto aggregato
di questa contrazione-dilatazione
è quello che determina poi
la contrazione o la dilatazione
del sistema cardiaco, in senso lato.
Perché dovremmo fidarci della matematica
per un problema così complesso?
Perché la matematica ci aiuta
a ragionare, a sviluppare
quello che oggi si chiama
il ragionamento computazionale,
ovvero affrontare un problema
nella sua complessità
partizionandolo in sotto-problemi,
ognuno con una sua logica intrinseca,
ma ogni sotto-problema
collegato agli altri sotto-problemi.
Queste capacità di sintesi
e di aggregazione concettuale
è quello che fa della matematica
uno strumento assolutamente potente
e vorrei dire unico.
Dobbiamo quindi essere capaci
di descrivere diverse macchine
che agiscono in sincronia nel cuore:
la macchina elettrofisiologica,
quindi il modello che descrive
la propagazione del potenziale elettrico
nel nostro sistema.
Poi la macchina biochimica,
quella che determina
il funzionamento di ogni singola cellula,
la sua polarizzazione o depolarizzazione.
Poi la macchina meccanica
perché c'è un effetto deformativo,
come abbiamo visto.
La macchina fluidodinamica,
perché abbiamo naturalmente il sangue
che è un fluido dentro le nostre cavità.
E poi infine l'attivazione delle valvole,
la dinamica valvolare.
Tutte queste macchine in realtà
sono dei modelli matematici che convivono,
si scambiano informazioni fra di loro
ed è esattamente
la risoluzione di questo problema,
che è dal punto di vista matematico
una mostruosità assoluta.
È straordinariamente complesso,
tradotto in equazioni
che traducono i principi fisici
fondamentali della nostra vita,
è la risoluzione di questo problema
che ci permetterà
di descrivere la funzione cardiaca
e anche la disfunzione cardiaca.
Non c'è nessun umano, nessun matematico,
capace di risolvere questo problema:
è troppo complesso,
straordinariamente complesso.
Abbiamo bisogno
della mediazione dei calcolatori.
Abbiamo bisogno di tradurlo
al finito, di approssimarlo,
renderlo fruibile al calcolatore,
attraverso gli algoritmi molto complessi,
attraverso un linguaggio
di programmazione.
E sarà poi calcolatore
che ci aiuterà a trovare una risposta
e quindi a rappresentare
questa realtà virtuale
che descrive il funzionamento
del nostro cuore.
Questo è il problema
che dobbiamo risolvere.
La simulazione è l'elemento fondamentale:
partire dal problema esatto
che non sappiamo risolvere,
tradurlo in un problema
risolvibile sul calcolatore
e poi effettuare la simulazione
del comportamento cardiaco.
Ovviamente il paziente è l'attore
fondamentale in questo discorso,
l'individuo.
Abbiamo bisogno di acquisire dati.
I dati vengono acquisiti dalle indagini
della risonanza magnetica, per esempio,
ma la cosa importante è riuscire a passare
da questa rappresentazione
che è una rappresentazione
per sezioni, come vedete,
ad un modello geometrico
completo, come questo.
Questo è il primo passo.
Il secondo passo è quello
di tradurre questo modello geometrico
con degli elementi geometrici
molto piccoli,
gli elementi di una ipotetica
griglia di calcolo.
Alla fine del processo saremo capaci
di descrivere la soluzione
in ogni elemento di questa griglia.
Quanti ne sono necessari?
Dipende dalla accuratezza.
Un milione, 10 milioni, 100 milioni,
a volte un miliardo?
Arriveremo a risolvere problemi
di un miliardo di equazioni
per descrive il comportamento umano.
Queste sono le fibre del muscolo cardiaco,
anche queste riprodotte
con un algoritmo matematico,
perché difficilmente rilevabili
in termini di risonanza magnetica
o ritmografia assiale.
Questa è già la simulazione,
questi sono già dei cuori matematici.
Qui vedete l'atrio sinistro,
e c'è un fronte che avanza,
ed è il fronte del potenziale elettrico.
Ci sono colori diversi,
il rosso è il massimo,
ogni intensità di colore
indica l'intensità del fenomeno
quindi la quantità di potenziale
in questo caso specifico.
Bene, stiamo descrivendo
come in un cuore sano
il potenziale elettrico si propaga
nel nostro atrio sinistro.
Qui descriviamo come un ventricolo sano
si deforma in tempo reale,
adesso vedete la velocità vera,
qui è soltanto decelerata,
questa è la velocità vera
di pulsazione cardiaca.
A sinistra vediamo una immagine laterale,
a destra un'immagine dall'alto.
Capite come, ad ogni stato,
il nostro cuore si contragga
dal punto di vista
della sua lunghezza, di circa il 30%,
si dilati ancora di una percentuale
dell'ordine del 25%
e poi dia luogo ad una torsione
assolutamente straordinaria.
E questo movimento incredibile
per certi aspetti molto poco naturale,
molto poco ovvio, molto poco lineare,
che fa sì che il cuore
abbia questo tipo di rendimento.
Quello che vedete è un cuore vero
di una persona vera,
sono due ventricoli che vedete dall'alto,
Adesso li vediamo decelerati,
quindi rallentati.
Quello è il potenziale cardiaco,
il potenziale elettrico
si sta propagando nei ventricoli.
Questo è un cuore malato, un cuore
che ha una patologia che si chiama LBBB
è sostanzialmente un blocco
di una parte del miocardio
dovuta per esempio ad un infarto.
É evidente che la propagazione,
come se fosse un'onda
che incontra un ostacolo,
viene deviata, dà luogo a variazioni,
a interazioni di onde,
è come se sviluppasse
un movimento sostanzialmente caotico.
Ovviamente i cuori
di questo tipo vanno curati
e la matematica può aiutare
a capire come intervenire,
con quali tipi di ablazioni,
per fare in modo che queste onde anomale
vengano ricondotte nel loro alveo
di comportamento naturale.
Questo è un cuore sano,
questa è una simulazione che vi fa capire
come il flusso di sangue
si comporti nel nostro cuore.
In alto vedete l'atrio sinistro,
in basso vedete il ventricolo sinistro.
Il sangue arriva
dalle quattro vene polmonari.
Il sangue ossigenato
entra nell'altro sinistro,
si dà luogo ad una dinamica
piuttosto complessa nell'altro sinistro.
Quando la pressione del sangue
supera la pressione di resistenza
della valvola mitrale
questa valvola si apre, il sangue
entra nel ventricolo sinistro in basso
ovviamente va a gonfiare,
ad amplificare il ventricolo sinistro.
Quando questa pressione è ancora superiore
a quella esercitata dell'arteria aorta
la valvola aortica si apre,
il sangue viene espulso
e viene mandato
nel nostro sistema circolatorio.
Capite che è un movimento molto complesso,
non c'è nessuna indagine radiologica,
risonanza magnetica, o tomografia
che possa rappresentare il movimento
con questo tipo di realismo.
Ma vorrei dire soprattutto, con
questo tipo di significato quantitativo -
questa non è solo un'indagine qualitativa
ma un'indagine quantitativa -
Questo è lo stesso tipo di simulazione,
qui vediamo la formazione
delle strutture vorticose
e non è esattamente turbolento
il flusso che si sviluppa nel cuore,
ma è quasi turbolento,
dà luogo di una vorticità
che è assolutamente straordinaria,
e grazie a questa vorticità
che non abbiamo nessuna zona
di stagnazione nel nostro ventricolo
ed è grazie a questo fatto
che i nostri ventricoli restano puliti
e che il cuore continua a comportarsi
in maniera straordinariamente efficace.
Questa è un'altra simulazione ancora,
vedete l'apertura della valvola aortica -
sono i tre lembi, i tre foglietti
della valvola aortica
che si chiudono e si aprano
per permettere ovviamente al sangue
di fuoriuscire ed entrare
nell'aorta ascendente,
che è quella che vedete in alto.
Queste sono simulazioni
straordinariamente efficaci
dal punto di vista
della qualità del risultato,
sono anche simulazioni
straordinariamente complesse
per darvi un'idea qualitativa,
un secondo di vita reale.
Quindi un battito cardiaco
che prende circa un secondo
richiede su un grosso calcolatore,
diciamo il più grande calcolatore europeo
circa una settimana di tempo
di calcolo dedicato.
Perché tutto questo?
Perché la matematica che ci sta dietro
è estremamente potente e raffinata,
e perché la nostra vita
è una vita complessa, molto ricca.
Il cuore ha un funzionamento
straordinariamente complesso da catturare,
l'algoritmo matematico
che utilizziamo, è capace di darci -
in ogni millesimo di secondo,
quindi mille volte
per ogni battico cardiaco -
l'evoluzione completa
del fenomeno cardiaco.
Siamo tutti differenti,
ognuno di noi ha un cuore diverso
da ogni altra persona.
Non solo, ma a tempi diversi
in momenti diversi,
il nostro cuore si comporta
in maniera differente.
Come tener conto di questa variabilità?
Questa è una delle cose molto difficili.
Dobbiamo tener conto di come
la variabilità di tanti cuori diversi
è condizionata dalla forma, che è
ovviamente diversa dai dati biologici,
quindi ad esempio dalla viscosità
e densità del nostro sangue,
diverso da una persona all'altra,
dalla distribuzione
delle fibre del miocardio
che variano in uno spazio
di dimensione infinita, sostanzialmente,
e poi dei dati funzionali,
cioè il nostro stato di salute
in quel preciso istante.
Come tenere conto
di tutta questa variabilità?
Questa è una grandissima sfida
per noi matematici.
E questo il nostro sogno,
il sogno è quello
di una medicina patient-specific
ovvero vorremmo essere in grado,
domani, di produrre questi risultati
per ogni singola persona
e, se possibile, in tempo reale.
Cosa significa tempo reale?
In un tempo che sia adatto e conveniente
per l'analisi del medico in corsia.
Per fare questo bisogna mettere in piedi
un modo di ragionare matematico
completamente differente
da quello tradizionale,
quindi esplorare una grandissima varietà
di pazienti o di persone,
quelle che vedete rappresentate in alto.
Per ognuno di questi,
fare queste simulazioni accurate
con i supercalcolatori,
mettere via in database ricchissimo
tutte queste simulazioni
e poi quando arriva un nuovo soggetto
esplorare e sfruttare, in modo
conveniente, le simulazioni di prima,
in modo tale da rendere la simulazione
per quello specifico soggetto
molto agile molto rapida e fattibile,
addirittura su uno smartphone
per essere utilizzato,
in tempo reale, dal medico.
Questo è il nostro obiettivo,
questo il nostro sogno,
ma non siamo, io penso, troppo lontani
dalla possibilità di realizzarlo.
Allora, vorrei concludere
dandovi un messaggio.
Questo è un tipo di matematica,
quello che sviluppiamo
per il sistema cardiocircolatorio.
Per la medicina in senso lato
io ho parlato di questa applicazione,
ma naturalmente
si può cercare di generalizzare.
È un tipo di matematica
accurata e quantitativa
quindi complementa in maniera perfetta
la conoscenza clinica
che è ovviamente molto basata
sulla conoscenza e sull'esperienza,
sull'arte del medico
e sulla esperienza vissuta,
e anche naturalmente
sulle immagini radiologiche -
che sono immagini che permettono
di prendere delle foto istantanee.
E sono delle foto, come abbiamo visto
prima, di particolari specifici,
per esempio delle sezioni
del sistema cardiocircolatorio.
É una matematica accurata,
l'accuratezza è nelle mani del matematico.
Abbiamo la possibilità di decidere
con quale accuratezza fornire i risultati.
Questo è un controllo del sistema che
è fatto ovviamente grazie alla matematica.
È una matematica non invasiva
e questo è importantissimo.
Non abbiamo bisogno di sottomettere
il paziente ad altre indagini.
Quindi non è invasiva, non è intrusiva,
è una matematica virtuale,
è un approccio individuale fatto
con carta e penna e computer naturalmente,
ma nei laboratori scientifici
quindi non abbiamo bisogno
di acquisire nuove indagini
e quindi ovviamente essere più di impatto
dal punto di vista personale,
dal punto di vista sociale
ed economico, sul paziente.
È una matematica predittiva.
Non voglio soltanto capire
cosa sta succedendo
in quel momento, a quella persona,
voglio pensare di poter prevedere cosa
succederà a quella persona nel futuro.
Quindi voglio fare la simulazione
esattamente come quando faccio
le previsioni del tempo
voglio capire oggi come sarà
il tempo, domani e dopodomani.
Vorrei poter usare questi modelli per
capire com'è l'evoluzione di un paziente,
in particolare se un certo tipo
di patologia si svilupperà
in una certa maniera
o in un'altra maniera.
Questo tipo di sguardo in avanti,
ancora una volta,
è una caratteristica fondamentale
che la matematica garantisce.
È una matematica che vorrebbe essere,
come detto prima, patient-specific.
Quindi vorremmo domani
essere capaci di dire:
questo è il cuore
di questa specifica persona,
questo cuore specifico si comporta e
si comporterà esattamente in questa modo.
Questo è un sogno,
ma lavoriamo per questo.
E infine vorrei dire che è una matematica
sostanzialmente a costo zero,
perché naturalmente c'è l'investimento
della conoscenza, della ricerca,
dell'intelligenza,
ma poi da poter utilizzare
in maniera sostanzialmente gratuita.
Questo credo che sia
il messaggio importante.
Una volta i greci pensavano,
nell'antichità,
che il cuore fosse lo scrigno
dei nostri sentimenti.
Questo è corroborato,
in qualche modo, da qualche evidenza.
Una forte emozione positiva,
la prima volta che ci innamoriamo,
fa reagire il cuore certamente
in maniera estremamente vitale.
Se abbiamo una emozione molto negativa
parliamo di cuore spezzato
e questo effettivamente si può tradurre
a volte in una liberazione di ormoni
tali da distribuirsi poi
nel sistema cardio-circolatorio
e quindi avere un impatto
non ancora chiaro
sul comportamento del cuore.
Non siamo ancora a questi livelli
di capire come coniugare
emozioni, sentimenti, passioni,
e comportamento fisiologico
e patologico del cuore.
Con la matematica siamo però già vicini
a poter descrivere l'azione
e la disfunzione cardiaca
in termini estremamente precisi.
Grazie!
(Applausi)